next I'd like to present our silver
medal winner another winner from UCLA
animator Joaquin Baldwin created this
film titled Sebastian's voodoo please
welcome our silver medal award winning
animation Joaquin Baldwin a keen thank
you undress we had had such a wonderful
time this last past past couple days
with the Academy it's you won't believe
how spoiled we were it was really
amazing with joint enjoyed every single
second of it I'd really wanted to thank
the Academy the Board of Governors ASC
wga everyone involved in this event it
has been really amazing and I'm sure it
will open a lot of doors for us i also
want to offer thanks to my composure
nick football i think he did a wonderful
outstanding job with the soundtrack also
to my partner Gus for being there for me
all this time my beautiful agent
Elizabeth my friends Wesson Scott for
being here for me tonight really this is
a great honor and I'm sure great things
will come out of this for all the
winners I'm sure we'll see each other in
the future very soon thank you
you